well Patriots and RAM supporters think
their team has what it takes to win
Super Bowl 53 but how do the super
cities compare as part of our annual
tradition we decided to find out CBS
Sunday mornings Morocco went to Patriots
country New England and CBS this morning
Saturday it's a fighting weekend between
these two co-hosts Michelle Miller went
to Los Angeles the home of the Rams
Michelle good morning good morning well
everyone who knows me knows I was
pulling for the New Orleans Saints
a big fan I am but I am originally from
LA and I'm always proud to show off the
City of Angels which coincidentally is
where our Mo Rocca is this morning hey
mo good morning Michelle trust me I'd
rather be joining you from beautiful New
England but I'm holed up here behind
enemy lines at this hotel suite in Los
Angeles so we might as well just begin
our tale of two cities from here
welcome to beautiful in sunny Southern
California where there's no better place
to live out the American Dream okay so
it's the dead of winter in New England
what can I say
we like the seasons and in Providence
Rhode Island you get to enjoy them all
wait a second
Providence aren't you supposed to be
back in Boston as great as shitty as
Boston is Michelle the Patriots play for
all of New England besides we both spent
the past two years looking at all things
Boston the daily fresh catch in the
harbor bonus custom green actors dumping
teeth
we all remember your truely
olympic-level ice-skating performance in
Boston calm and I mean that wasn't like
it was a body double
besides Rhode Island is steeped in its
own history it was the first colony to
take military action against the British
crown right here in Narragansett Bay but
most importantly polls show Patriots
fans from Rhode Island are the most
enthusiastic superfan like SNL alum
Taran Killam check out this view
Michelle the Rhode Island Coast and
Newport Harbor have long been the
destination of titans of industry like
the Vanderbilts and Taylor Swift
now this is a view and this is the
Griffith Observatory where more than a
million and a half visitors come every
year and look to the star if you prefer
your stars closer to the ground no
better place to see them than on the
streets of LA oh my God look I'm
Michelle
stop the presses Michelle America's
oldest continually publish daily
newspaper is the Providence Journal and
Providence is the home of Cory Pesa
churro
you know the three-time world champion
on the accordion you know that song it's
a grand old flag written by provenances
own George M :
[Music]
well as I'm sure he knows Providence has
the most doughnut shops per capita of
any city in America mmm fruity pebbles
do you want a donut
that's a donut and Randy's Donuts is a
classic la landmark sorry to bug you
Michelle but the mascot for the big blue
bug pest control company is the largest
termite replica in the world you are
spoiling my appetite mo and that's hard
to do in LA I mean whether you're
craving the critically acclaimed Korean
barbecue
for these Fanta Keita's and alvera
Street you can experience LA's diverse
culture through cuisine and nearly
30,000 restaurants in LA County well I
bet a bunch of those chefs came from
Johnson & Wales University here in
Providence where some of the world's top
chefs earn their chops to teach them how
to make a French Dip mo the sandwich was
created right here at Philippe's
and maybe it was cold either way hey
it's the largest Bell cast by Paul
Revere hit it and get this people in LA
can thank Providence for powering
American expansion out west
since the largest locomotives ever were
built right here what about the world's
shortest railway Angels Flight was built
right here in downtown LA back in 1901
thank you Hugh isn't the word I'd use to
describe chill let's Stadium in
Foxborough Massachusetts where the
Patriots rule meanwhile the Rams headed
to LA without a stadium of their own
you're right mo but their temporary home
the Los Angeles Memorial Coliseum has
been called the greatest stadium in the
world built in 1923 it is the only venue
to host not just one but two Olympic
Games I was in the opening ceremonies
back in 84 it will host a third in 2028
and this is LA Stadium at Hollywood Park
future home of the soon-to-be NFL
champion it'll be ready by 2020
check out those hard hats
that's the kind of attention to detail
you gotta have you're building a dynasty
Tom Brady has already built a dynasty
with Super Bowl win number six on the
way and there's so much worn you England
to explore let's go
you know I'm thinking Portland Maine oh
you know you who has great piece that
you Haven Connecticut so much to see
Montpelier Vermont it is five degrees at
the Patriots standing right now in
Foxborough yeah Foxborough is not the
place to be guys that was so well done
very funny
great acting acting acting can I say no
that was her essence I'm directing that
to moe very funny as usual I I do all my
own stunts so I'd be clear about that
eating that doughnut stunt Rudy pebble
Matt termite sculpture had made that
yeah
my favorite part might be the blue bug
that's all I need to say like what 70
degree weather isn't it fabulous
loving it well thanks to both of you
that was a lot of fun nice to always
focus on different cities and choose
other than Boston because there's a lots
of fans through Connecticut and the rest
of England as always may the best team
win
and a shout outs are our producer Jill
young and Craig Shay you know it was a
lot of fun that's always come out thank
you so long okay thank you and you can
watch Super Bowl 53 and all the pregame
action right here on CBS starting at
6:00 p.m. Eastern this Sunday and
earlier that day on CBS Sunday morning
you can catch musician Linda Ronson and
oscar-nominated actor Sam Elliott Plus
be sure to check out the newest episode
of Moe's podcasts I'm a big fan Mo
bitchu Aries out today
it's all about folks who are ahead of
their time